Next up, it's a real pleasure I get to
introduce
a friend Urbashi Mitra is the Gordon S.
Marshall Professor of Engineering at the
University of Southern California.
Urbashi received her
bachelor's and master's from Berkeley
and PhD from Princeton and she's
currently the Gordon S. Marshall
Professor of Engineering with
appointments in electrical engineering
and computer science. And I have to tell
a really brief story because we've both
Urbashi and I have both been
participating in this conference called
KFirst World
at Stanford every year and which has a
lot of knowledge graph content.
And I a year ago
she'd given my favorite talk.
And and I just come away with my mind
blown. I come back this year, same thing
again. So I I
begged and pleaded could we please bring
this content about causal graphs here to
to Connected Data London. And so the
topic is causal graph identification,
optimization, performance bounds and
reward optimization. Please join me in
welcoming Urbashi.
>> [applause]
>> Thank you very much. Um I really
appreciate Paco convincing the
organizers to let me come speak to you.
I can safely say this will be something
completely different.
Um
I want to start by telling you a little
bit about myself and what my day job
generally consists of. I do a lot of
work in structured statistics and
information theory and my original work
was looking at optimization and design
of wireless communication networks. And
when I finished my PhD 30 years ago, it
was completely legitimate to study
point-to-point communications which is
one transmitter, one receiver. But now
the entire world is starting to focus on
graphs and I too as a wireless
communications person, cannot worry
about point-to-point communications, but
need to worry about how we transfer
information across these complex graphs
with many nodes, heterogeneous data,
etc. I don't know how many of you caught
the masterclass yesterday by Amy Hodler
and Andrea Fronca teaching causal graph
inference and analysis. It was a really
nice presentation, and if you missed it,
I think you can still stream it. Um
looking at causal inference is actually
a very old problem. If you take a look
at the statistics literature, you will
see that individuals, the giants of
statistics, started worrying about these
problems as early as the 1920s.
Things that they were worried about were
really cause and effect issues, and in
our modern language, we would call it
interventions. If I do this kind of
intervention, use this medication, uh
purify water in this way, what is the
outcome going to be? And then it sort of
progressed, and there was a big step
change in the 1990s, largely due to the
generation of ideas and proselytization
of people like Judea Pearl, who many
people consider to be sort of the father
of modern causal inference. And that
defined a lot of what happened in that
field perhaps for the next 10 years or
so, maybe even 15. And the presentation
that Amy and Andrea gave yesterday is
very much in the spirit of the Judea
Pearl family of how to think about
causal inference in graphs. And it's
very important, but it has some
challenges, and one of the big
challenges has to do with the fact that
these methods are provably good. They
always work if you meet the right
conditions, and as a result, they end up
being computationally very expensive
because they are inherently
combinatorial. You have to check if a
lot of conditions hold or don't hold,
and if they do, you can make some very
strong statements. So, I feel that as a
community, we have evolved uh the recent
past. I would say in the last 10 15
years. Now we're taking a more
statistics view on these kinds of
problems, which means we're allowing
ourselves to make some mistakes, have
some noise, and have some trade-offs
between complexity uh and performance.
And so what I want to do today
uh through the lens of being
self-aggrandizing and talking about the
research that my group is doing is to
give you a little bit of of a feel of
the kinds of problem statements we think
about and also to offer you the
potential Well, I want to encourage you
to think about working with academics
like myself because especially for those
of us that are in electrical
engineering, we are very much interested
in application-driven research. We want
to understand your problems. What are
the unique features of your domain?
Because every time there's a new domain,
there are new constraints and um
selfishly that means for me there's a
new algorithm. So uh which means
publication then all things are good. So
what did I go ahead and get started? So
um I like this toy example. This came
from a real position paper that I found
online. I guess I should step back for a
moment um and forgive the professor hat
here, but how many of you know about
causal graphs?
Okay, a handful. Have you looked at or
played with causal inference algorithms?
Okay, smaller. All right, great. So um
I I think this is an example that we can
all relate to. So again, this is
something that was put out by
researchers at Lyft where of course
their objective is to maximize revenue
through maximizing the number of rides
that actually occur. And they've looked
at a variety of features that could
influence the number of rides that are
involved here.
And so I don't know what strategies they
used in order to come up with this
causal graph. This could be their
knowledge graph. They simply through um
expert knowledge etc. figured out that A
influences B, but the goal of uh causal
inference is to have an understanding of
what each of those nodes are, have
observations of those values, and then
use that collection of data to figure
out um the directions of the arrows, but
also weights on the arrows. Which node
is more influential on the other?
And so, one of the things that I've been
thinking about over the last 2 days, and
also starting with this interaction at K
first and meeting Paco, is you know, a
causal graph is not exactly a knowledge
graph. All right? Uh a knowledge graph,
the nodes of them may not be data
generators. And so, an interesting
question for us to understand and think
about in the future is how do we merge
this inherent knowledge that are in
these knowledge graphs to causal graph
identification. So, I will put forth to
you that if you already know what
influences what, and have a sense of the
strength of that influence, you don't
need someone like me or these
algorithms. The The interesting part
occurs when we try to bring these ideas
together, and in particular, try to
understand how we can use knowledge
graphs as prior information. And as
someone who, again, does structured
statistics, we always want to know what
the priors are in order to generate um
high-performance specialized algorithms.
So, at the risk of being a heretic, I
don't want to do AGI. All right? Because
general means that it's going to
hallucinate, it's going to be fragile,
etc. But if I can do ASI, where I'm
using S as smaller specialized, then we
have some hope of solving problems.
Okay. So, as I said, what I'd like to
do, these are my goals, is to learn the
topology. How do these nodes interact
with each other? What are the direction
of the arrows? And what are the values,
if you will? And notice if in my toy
example, and I made up these numbers, I
don't know if they have anything to do
with Lyft's causal graph, but some of
the numbers are negative. All right? So,
there can be things that are negatively
influential. Uh I want to understand the
weights and directions, and my talk is
in two parts, and in the second part, in
addition to learning the graph, I also
want to optimize some kind of reward.
Um, in this case, if I'm Lyft, it would
be the number of rides. And so, we'll be
interested in modifying behavior so that
we can maximize rewards while learning
the graph. So, I want to do I want to
walk and chew gum at the same time.
All right. So, if you are a follower of
the Judea Pearl view of causality in the
world, he talks about this ladder of
causality and how in the early days,
when we were figuring out correlations
or associations between nodes or
behaviors, we were sort of at this
lowest rung. And I would say even causal
graph identification on some level is at
this low lowest rung because you're
trying to understand these influences.
As we become more sophisticated, we try
to understand interventions. So, I have
an understanding of A influencing B, but
if I now change the environment, I give
you a medication, I offer you a coupon,
how is this going to change the graph
that underlies the system? What we
really want to get at is this top rung,
which is counterfactuals, which is to
ask kinds of the questions of
"How healthy would I be now if 10 years
ago I stopped eating ice cream?" All
right, I can't go back in time, but if
there is enough model data information
out there, I might be able to ask that
kind of question, especially when it
comes to designing things in the future,
right? So, can I decide how I might make
these sorts of designs? So,
people are working on counterfactuals.
It's, I think, very much in its infancy,
and there's a lot to be done, especially
since we still have a lot to do even at
the lowest rung in terms of association,
and in particular, when it comes to this
performance complexity trade-off.
So, again, I I want to underscore that
people have been working on these
problems for a while and even in our own
work, we've been trying to assess what
are the state-of-the-art algorithms that
we should be looking at. And
interestingly enough, there are things
from the 2010s and shortly after that
that remain sort of the state-of-the-art
when it comes to causal inference. So,
there's still a lot of room and in fact,
some of the theoretical work that I'm
going to show you today
essentially shows you that these
so-called state-of-the-art algorithms
are very far from what we can do. So,
there's still a lot of room for
improvement. Now,
because we are driven by particular
applications, there's some things that
we noticed in the literature that were
quite important to us that I want to
emphasize. And that is in the discovery
of this graph, is there an edge? Is
there not an edge? What's the direction
of the edge? Most of this prior art
assumes that any of the kinds of
mistakes that you might make are equally
deleterious, all right? And in many
applications, this is in fact not the
case. The other thing that we see is a
lot of the prior art needs a lot of
data, many observations in order to make
decisions.
And if you look at a lot of modern
problems, you will hear people use the
language big data.
Oftentimes when they say big data, they
mean that the data is very high
dimensional, but they don't mean that I
have millions of realizations of this
particular data. And so, we are
operating in the regime where maybe your
data is high dimensional, but you don't
have a lot of copies of it. And when I
say copies, I mean did you run a million
experiments so that I have that many
observations by which I can build
statistics and design some of these
algorithms.
Okay. So, to underscore this point that
I just made, um I have a toy graph here.
It has four nodes. You can see um the
black lines correspond to my so-called
true directions between the nodes
influencing each of them. We're going to
see later that these X's correspond to
observations at the of those nodes,
which might be number of rides, the
weather at a particular location over 2
months, etc.
And I could use two different algorithms
that will come up with two estimates of
you if you will of this causal graph.
I'm not worrying about weights yet. And
in both of the examples, they're both
wrong. And according to most of the
prior algorithms, they are equally wrong
because they both have two mistakes. One
has introduced edges that didn't exist
in the true graph, and the other one
removed edges that did exist in the true
graph. And again, in our applications,
and I think for a lot of applications
that you care about, these are
completely unequal problems, all right?
And I would argue, depending on what
nodes or KPIs you are, that you might
care differently about the presence or
absence of a link. And we believe with
the methods that we've created, we're
actually now in a
in a position, although it's going to be
computationally expensive, to actually
take those errors link by link and
decide which whether a false positive or
a false negative is more important.
And so again, I don't think I have to
sell this to you, you know, which one of
these errors is more critical to you is
very much application dependent. We've
been interacting with microbiologists
who are trying to understand the
underlying gene networks in these simple
single-cellular organisms. And for them,
interestingly enough, false positives on
our side mean they have to do
experiments that they shouldn't have to
do. On the other hand, if you're, you
know, in the medical field, then a false
negative might be more important to you.
Okay. So, um
not only am I standing between you and
drinks, cocktails,
being the last talk, I've also decided
to introduce equations, which is
probably something one should not do in
this particular community. I apologize,
but I it's very hard for me to not have
equations. So, um
I hope some of you have had linear
algebra, but these are very simple
equations. They actually belie the
challenge in doing causal graph
identification because if you look at
this,
what I have So, what's invisible here is
that there are these epsilons coming
into every node. It's like a exogenous
inputs often modeled by some form of
noise. And then I have these connections
which literally, for this example,
correspond to linear equations. Notice
that I don't allow for any self loops,
so there are no loops going backward on
each other. So, if you come up with a
parsimonious representation of this, you
essentially have either upper or lower
triangular matrices. So, on some level,
by trying to learn what this matrix B is
by looking at realizations of the X, you
can rearrange it and it's actually a
linear equation, which you would think
would be super easy to solve except that
I have to ensure that I have a directed
acyclic graph. And in many situations,
the number of connections are sparse and
I want to take that side information
into consideration. And so, these
various constraints actually convert
this into a nonlinear problem.
So, um So, this is what I want to do. I
want to figure out this matrix B, which
has an edge direction, weight, etc.
So, in the first piece of work that um
I want to talk to you about, we looked
at this from a very theoretical point of
view which asked the question of can I
figure out what is called the skeleton,
which is just the presence or absence of
links between various nodes. And we took
a statistical approach that said, "I'm
going to look at one link at a time
and compare the statistics under both
cases." This ends up being conceptually
a very straightforward thing to do, but
in practice, it's very challenging to
design because the underlying statistics
of these cases are very hard to compute
because there's so many of them. Um I
think this got mentioned during the
master class yesterday, but we often go
through this sort of
toy computation of look how few nodes it
takes and how many candidate directed
acyclic graphs there are out there. So,
with as little as eight nodes, I have,
you know, almost 10 to the 12 different
possibilities. So, computing the
statistics under these situations
becomes computationally very expensive.
I don't have the technical results here,
but I will tell you that this strategy,
computationally expensive as it is, is a
very easy to analyze. So, I can make
some very strong theoretical statements
about how quickly I learn and how does
my accuracy change as a function of the
number of observations that I have, but
when you plot performance against
state-of-the-art strategies, again, and
you will see some of these plots,
there's a huge gap between what this
optimal detector can do and what people
are using right now. To me, this says
that there's tremendous room for growth
for people to come up with new moderate
complexity strategies
for graph identification. So, again,
this is computationally very expensive.
So, this is unfortunate. So, we wanted
to worry about cheaper ways of trying to
design these strategies.
And again, I need to underscore going
back here that in the design of the
so-called optimal test, I am controlling
for either false positives or false
negatives. So, I can guarantee you that
my detector will give you the false
positive or false negative rate that you
want. And again, most strategies don't
worry about that. So, we designed a much
lower complexity algorithm that does
control edge errors. It's the red line
there. So, this is my false negative
rate and I want it to be as low as
possible as a as a function of the
so-called false positive rate. And what
you see above in the green and the sort
of yellow ochre lines are two of the
state-of-the-art strategies. Lasso is
based on sparse approximation
methodologies and ensures sparsity
in the system. And then Dagma is
So, you'll recall that earlier I said
there are these elegant strategies that
come out of the Judea Pearl way of
thinking about the world, but they are
inherently combinatorial and then also
computationally expensive. So, methods
like Dagma essentially convert these
combinatorial optimizations into
continuous ones, but they're still
somewhat expensive.
What's nice about the strategy that
we've designed and again for those of
you that are used to playing around with
neural network architectures, etc., is
that we have no hyperparameter tuning.
Right? So, you give me the false
positive rate that you want, I will give
you the best false negative or vice
versa, and I know exactly what to do and
how to set various thresholds within the
algorithm. So, this is something that's
that's nice, but it's
it's still expensive relative to other
strategies.
Uh
if you've been reading the slides
carefully, at least a third of you are
scoffing at the theoretical person on
the stage giving you these numerical
results because you're going to
recognize that this is a very small
graph, five nodes. I don't think any of
your knowledge graphs have five nodes,
they probably have hundreds. Um but, I
want to emphasize that there's only 10
samples here, which is like almost no
data. This is the kind of thing that my
grad students and I can do on our
laptops, it easily scales up. The
important thing is the relationship
between the number of nodes and the
number of samples, right? So, we're in a
regime that if you give me my GPU or my
servers, I can make this work well and
and you know, computationally
efficiently.
Can I go even cheaper?
So, to overcome this complexity
challenge, uh
we've introduced an idea which to me
must have been done before, but we can't
seem to find it. So, if anyone knows,
please tell us. And that is instead of
trying to learn the whole graph, we
learn sub graphs. And these sub graphs
are created in a very particular way
because if we essentially say, "I'm a
node, let's pick an interesting one,
number five here, who are my parents?"
That's the mini graph that I want to
learn. I only want to learn who my
parents are. And it turns out that this
is equivalent to learning, say, columns
or rows of that being matrix one at a
time. And by enforcing properties of the
graph, like it's a directed acyclic
graph, we can ensure consistencies
across the entire graph. And this is
much cheaper than learning the whole
graph at a time, and it works
surprisingly well.
And so, one of the things that we are
going to exploit harkens back to
classical strategies in causal graph
identification, which is the principle
of independent mechanisms, and
essentially says that the causal
variables are statistically independent
of the effect-producing mechanism, which
means we can design a pretty
straightforward statistical test that
looks at the um mutual information
between errors that we make and
essentially uh the parents, if you will.
Now,
in any kind of strategy like this, we
saw before examples of the mistakes you
could make, false positives, false
negatives. I can also make a mistake in
terms of the value of the weight. And
so, we looked at the impact of different
kinds of errors on these kinds of
strategies. And so, for example, what
the student has labeled an intrinsic
error means I have the correct edge, but
the incorrect weight value, or I could
have the wrong edge, in this case a
false positive. And they affect my
errors differently. Now, one of the
things that's interesting is that small
errors can still have a big impact in
terms of percolating through the system.
And so, the sort of secret sauce that
was introduced by the student in this
case was recognizing that even if an
edge weight is small and therefore the
causal error a
I still need to um incorporate this into
my algorithm design. And so we created a
new regularization that gives us very
strong improvement in our results. So to
emphasize how important this
regularization is, let's take a look
again at the graph false negative rate
here. Here um I'm increasing the number
of nodes. I want to emphasize that it's
bigger than what I had before and it
could be much bigger. What is
constraining us here is our competition
algorithms. They start to
meet the limits of our computational
abilities at 20 nodes, but ours does
not. We could keep going.
And so what I really want So there's
perhaps two or three big ideas that I
want you to see. The first is that if we
don't take this regularization into
consideration, I get the purple line,
which basically says I have a very large
false negative rate, not acceptable. And
then if Yes, that's that's bad. One is
not good. Um and that our new strategies
uh based on this causal subgraph
learning give us the smallest false
negative rate that we see here relative
to the other state-of-the-art
algorithms. And as the number of nodes
gets larger, you see everyone else um
starts to fail as well. All right. So
what is challenging the state-of-the-art
methodologies is the fact that they're
trying to learn the whole graph at the
at the same time. And this becomes
harder and harder sort of exponentially
as the number of nodes increases.
Okay. So let's do one last thing um
before you can get your pint, which is
So we worried about learning the graph.
Now I want to ask the question of how
should I design interventions so I can
optimize some kind of reward, all right?
So if I'm Lyft, for example, I could
potentially change the coupon budget,
all right? Or I could change the number
of hours that somebody works. Or I could
change the price. These are all levers
that are at my disposal. Now one of the
things that we are going to investigate
is an environment which I can apply
interventions, but I don't necessarily
know how that's going to affect the
graph because we believe this is a more
realistic environment to consider.
And I'll go through examples of
interventions. But, what I want to
emphasize, going back to this early
statement that I made that false
positives and false negatives can affect
things differently, for this particular
problem, false negatives in the graph
learning have a significant impact on my
optimization of interventions and
maximization of my rewards. All right,
so, in this particular application, for
example, if I'm Lyft, I really care if
I'm getting a particular kind of edge
incorrectly estimated in my graph.
All right, so again, people have been
worrying about this as well
uh with varying amounts of known
information. So, there's known topology
and known information about the
interventions, known topology but
unknown interventional distributions,
and then the much more challenging case
which we're working on right now is
unknown topology and unknown
interventional distributions. Even
though there is a lot new work emerging
in this particular space that we are
trying to compete in, it tends to be
very restricted in terms of its
assumptions. And I
I believe one of the contributions that
my student was able to make is to
strongly um generalize things. I do want
to highlight this bolded work here which
has finally come out in the Journal of
Machine Learning Research because it
essentially um is what inspired us to do
this particular work, and you'll see we
do a comparison to their strategy where
they know the topology, but they don't
know the intervention.
So,
what are the different things that can
happen, or what are the different kinds
of interventions people have considered?
So, again, here's a very simple
three-node network.
Hard intervention just says, I've
decided, you know, the price is this, or
I've decided the weather is raining,
which again might seem artificial and it
is because there are situations in which
you cannot declare the value of a node
because you don't have any control over
it. What we're going to do is a
so-called soft intervention, which means
we we change um we do apply an
intervention, but we are not always
clear as to how it's going to change the
weights in the graph.
And what we're going to do is model this
as a multi-armed bandit where the arm
that I pull essentially corresponds to a
set of interventions. Many arms in this
problem, all right? And yet still um
because of the causal subgraph learning,
we're able to decompose things into a
much uh lower complexity problem. So,
there's a lot of math and analytics here
as to how to pull the arms and there's a
strategy that you use which says, I'm
going to pull arms such that I um reduce
a best-case uncertainty bound. And so,
again, this is sort of the math that
happened here, which I will hide from
you. But let me show you how it works.
Uh and so here, we have adapted some of
those state-of-the-art methods so that
they also have a multi-armed bandit
version. What we want to see in this
particular plot is that we find the
optimal intervention as often as
possible. So, in this graph, we want the
numbers to be large. What you see in the
purple line is the strategy that doesn't
know the interventional distributions,
but does know the topology. So, it has
side information. So, purple in a way is
what we call a genie-aided scheme. And
our strategy is the red one, and you see
that it gets near optimal much more
quickly than the other strategies. And
it's because embedded in this is the
subgraph learning. So, we are getting
much closer to learning the graph as we
go versus the other methodologies which
take some time to learn the graph.
And so, we're totally benefiting from
this.
Um
we can also look at how we're doing in
uh reward optimization. And so, the
technical term here is called regret,
where we essentially compare the optimal
reward to the reward that we are
achieving. And um as the term would
imply, in contrast to the previous slide
where you wanted to maximize things, now
we want to minimize our regret. So once
again, we see that, you know, we're the
red line, we're performing very close
um to the optimal regret, which is being
achieved by the strategy that already
knew the topology, but we're learning as
we go.
And so um
again, our ability to learn the graph
with our modified uncertainty bounds
gives us much better performance.
Okay. So I'm going to end by showing you
inspirations and applications. So we
first started thinking about this causal
graph learning problem because of
interaction that we had with um
microbiologists.
Uh Jo Handelsman is uh at the University
of Wisconsin. She was one of Obama's
science advisors. If I understand the
history correctly, she's the mother of
metagenomics, quite an important field,
um uh an important person in this field.
And they've been studying these
multi-species uh
communities. And this particular one,
which has three species in it, exists in
the wild. And most species multi-species
communities in the wild have hundreds of
species. If we checked your gut biome
right now, you'd have, you know, a
couple of a hundred in there.
And this particular community influences
um root health in soybean. So
agricultures all over trying to
understand what's going on here. So the
the short description is three species.
If two of them exist, one creates an
antibiotic that kills the other. If the
third one exists, everyone exists in
harmony. And why that third species
should have this kind of influence in
this community is something that is
still not well understood.
So we've been analyzing their data, and
one of the things that we found is that
they knew that the The
K node influenced everybody. Everyone
was well aware of that. But the fact
that the A's influenced each other,
these are genes within a single species,
that was a big surprise. So, we're now
waiting for them to do the experiments
to understand, you know, does this
effect actually exist? Because in the
end we're only manipulating 74
replicates. So, we don't know if, you
know, we are in the statistically
significant regime. Let me finish with
something that's just started up, which
was a bit of a surprise to us, talking
to colleagues at Notre Dame who are
computer engineers. They want to
optimize the efficiency and performance
of very large neural network
architectures. And one of the ways they
do this to reduce power use is they
quantize weights at the layers. And one
of the things that they've discovered is
that there are correlations and
interactions between the quantization
levels at different layers. And they do
a lot of, you know, combinatorial try
this, see what happens.
I assumed that the
the causal dependency would flow through
the network, right? I have my inputs and
then the second layer and then third
layer. Apparently, this is not true. And
so, what we're doing right now is using
our interventional approach, where the
interventions are the quantization
levels at each layer in the graph, to
see if we can tell them, you know,
what's the optimal amount of
quantization at each of the different
levels. And
to for us, at least, curiously try to
understand what are, you know, the the
directions and weights between different
layers. So, let me stop there by saying
we're very interested in tailored causal
graph learning for some of the things
that we've been looking at inspired by
the bio- biological applications. We
look at asymmetric errors and a small
number of samples. We're also very
interested in complexity. Our new
strategy for optimal detection shows
that there's a lot of room for
improvement in terms of moderate
complexity state-of-the-art strategies.
And one of the things that we want to do
now is
look at causal reinforcement learning.
And there's two possible directions
here.
To use causality to do reinforcement
learning, and to use reinforcement
learning to do causal graph learning.
And um
although I don't think I have to sell
you on this, but I've had to do this
with others, this is an actual causal
graph based on wireless network KPIs. I
can't tell you what each of the nodes
mean because I wasn't told. Um but from
a causal get Ericsson. So these large
companies are are very interested in
trying to understand these strategies
because especially for a company like
Ericsson, they want to improve network
resiliency and robustness. And so trying
to understand how errors percolate
through the network can have profound
implications in terms of their business.
Thank you very much.
>> [applause]
>> Thank you very much.
And also uh I there's one other part
that I definitely want to ask you about.
I I believe you have an ask for some of
the people in the audience here.
>> goodness, I do.
Ha, sorry. There was one more slide. So
um we're looking for partners. We're
looking for data that we can manipulate.
We're very interested in domain-specific
problems. And because I'm a PhD advisor,
I'm also looking for opportunities for
my students. I think that uh especially
um
Yoni and Chen, the two students that
worked on this work, they are very adept
in manipulating um
deep learning and neural network
strategies. Even though we don't work on
that, I need to make sure that everyone
knows how to design them and use them
because then we can show everyone that
our strategies always work better than
the deep learning strategies, largely
because we work in the low data regime.
Thank you.
>> Wonderful. Questions?
And can I just take a minute to
translate something into this audience?
>> Jeez.
>> Cuz we were talking about this Okay, one
of the implications here is suppose you
have a graph with hundreds of millions
of nodes, and it's in manufacturing or
finance or health care. It's something
you care about, right? There's a lot of
interactions
flowing from one node to another.
Um taking a page from FinCEN, financial
crime, looking at fraud.
Uh
if you were to talk about causal graphs
in the sense of looking at fraud at a
very large scale, that would be an
enormous amount of computation. I don't
even want to think about it before you
could get anywhere.
The innovation here is to say much like
we do case management in fraud,
where there may be a node there may be a
graph that has 5 billion nodes, but at
the end of the day we use things like
Louvain partitioning or modularization,
and then we we use centrality to
identify nodes of interest, and we end
up working cases that might have 10 or
20 nodes of potential fraud. We don't
look at 5 billion.
And the innovation here is to say, "Yes,
we can do the causal graph optimization
on those subgraphs of approximately that
size and get really great results." So,
if you want to be looking at say for
instance threat detection, where you
know that there is an intruder operating
on one of your assets, you know they had
to have gotten there somehow or another,
maybe through a phishing attack, but you
don't know the entry point,
this would be ideally the kind of way to
go after that. So, if you are working in
areas of finance or manufacturing where
some of this would help out, I I think
that they would very much like to
partner on data.
>> I Thank you. Um if I were not an
academic, I would say check's in the
mail, but I can't afford to write you a
check. So, um we also do a lot of
anomaly detection, I should say. This
predates the graph analysis work that
we've done, but that's of course um sort
of a mainstay of statistical signal
processing.
>> Any questions?
>> I think everyone wants a drink.
>> Okay, cocktails. Thank you very much,
Gretchen.
>> Thank you so much.